these hands just removed a woman's
pelvic organs for a student
demonstration it's 18 21 and I stuffed
them in my pocket to show my classroom
later I delivered a baby wearing these
same clothes and the mother died I slept
in my office didn't have time to change
I got up and helped students deliver
another baby and that mother died too a
few more mothers died in the next
weekend I don't know why I don't know
what's going on this scenario really
happened I took it directly from the
testimony of a Scottish doctor the
mothers all had pure Pearl fever some
call it child bed fever French
gynecologist Jacques erbo said epidemic
purepro fever is to women what war is to
men it cuts down its victims in the
prime of their lives it killed women
after childbirth and it killed newborn
babies too and even though it had been
around for thousands of years at least
since Hippocrates it was never really a
problem until it could wipe out one in
four mothers in early 19th century
hospitals and this epidemic which no one
could identify and no one could cure was
actually made worse by scientific
progress even when a Hungarian doctor
cracked the code of the most terrifying
disease a mother could face he became as
one of his biographers wrote a martyr to
the world's stupidity ignored condemned
criticized beaten and dead at 47 ignis
semelvice who eventually became known as
the savior of mothers has almost been
completely forgotten but he's one of the
reasons you grew up with the mother and
he's one of the reasons you grew up at
all so how did he solve a problem
problem that Europe's finest scientific
Minds couldn't even identify and why was
he punished for it
foreign
forties Europe the forearms of a medical
professional conducting an autopsy would
be entirely covered in bodily fluids up
to the Elbow including his shirt sleeves
the smell after the first abdominal
incision was so putrid literally the
scent of putrefaction decaying and dead
tissue that even the most experienced
doctor had to turn away and bury his
nose into his bent arm
yeah students witnessing the dissection
vomited and when the abdominal wall was
exposed it revealed a slimy yellow white
fluid called exudate a general word
doctors use to describe an excreted
fluid most doctors couldn't identify it
at all others realized it was pus and
more thought it was coagulated fermented
milk after using cloth strips to wipe
away the goo ignis summer Vice would
show his students the severe organ
inflammation that tracked the insides of
the new mother he just cut up it was
virtually the same scenario day after
day so common that morgue attendance
described entering the hospital as a
process of diagnose operate dye dissect
semelvice was born in 1818 in Buddha
part of modern Budapest in the Kingdom
of Hungary which was at the time part of
the Habsburg Austrian Empire as a young
man he studied law which he didn't like
and spent most of his time arguing at
coffee houses until a friend invited him
to an anatomy demonstration he enrolled
in the Vienna medical school then spent
two years at the University of pesh
before returning to Vienna his main
interest was actually in botany with a
dissertation called Davida plantarum on
the life of plants he switched to
obstetrics because he couldn't find a
job they're just more baby jobs than
botany Jobs when he was appointed to
algomon kronken house Vienna General
Hospital the finest Hospital in
Continental Europe there were two
clinics for birthing mothers some of ice
was similar to a chief resident in the
first Clinic which operated like a
teaching Hospital students from all over
Europe who are enrolled in Viennese
Medical School worked alongside highly
trained Physicians to examine mothers to
be participate in live births and engage
in follow-up care the second Clinic was
staffed by traditional midwives
epidemics of child bed fever raged
through the first Clinic with full rows
of patients Contracting the disease and
dying the second Clinic had a very low
rate of infection and epidemics were
rare this was semelvice's first problem
why did a disease run rampant through
One Wing of the hospital and not the
other and why did the most highly
trained doctors in Europe see a
shockingly high mortality rate among
their patients while the wing of
midwives just didn't same building
completely different outcomes
why the two clinics admitted patients on
alternating days so if you are a
pregnant mother in Vienna it was the
luck of the draw people knew the Grim
results of the first Clinic they tried
to time their deliveries to be admitted
to the second clinic but babies just
kind of go on their own schedule to
purposefully avoid the first Clinic
women would give Street births when a
woman arrived having already had her
baby she was admitted to the second
clinic for postnatal Care Street births
were meant to be a category of
emergencies like when a mother couldn't
get to the hospital in time but isn't it
worth taking your chances in your house
or in the back of a wagon or in some
cases even on the stairs to the clinic
to avoid being assigned to the death
wing and there was some irony to the
whole thing the the clinic set up to
prepare thousands of doctors to bring
life into the world was actually a
factory of death okay so this was the
dominant theory of the day for what
caused pure Pearl fever ready
ah
actually that's not entirely true
doctors felt that they did know and that
the disease was a mystifying combination
of factors too complex to comprehend in
the centuries after Hippocrates medical
wisdom dictated that disease was a
result of an imbalance of humors by the
1600s Thomas sydenum used the phrase
genius epidemicus to describe the
tangled web of natural factors that led
to illness eventually these theories
fell under a general description of
cosmic atmospheric teluric which
encompassed every possible natural
variable you could imagine did a group
of mothers develop pure Pearl fever
because the barometric pressure was bad
during a certain phase of the moon when
it rained on a day after the mothers
didn't get enough sunlight for a week
and then you can just sprinkle in God's
mysterious will and Earth's desire for
perfect to balance and voila you get an
epidemic you get an epidemic and you get
an epidemic the miasmic Theory made a
little more sense that diseased air
infected patients a purebro fever
epidemic in Paris In 1664 was believed
to be the result of locating a Maternity
Ward directly above a Surgical Clinic of
course an infectious Vapors which arose
from the wounds and ulcers of wounded
bodies created a mass of impure and
malignant air the air perpetually Rose
upward and was inhaled Day and Night by
the newly delivered women the women fell
into a bloody flux that ended only with
their death the uh stench of life in the
1800s is hard to comprehend human sewage
animal feces rotting garbage stagnant
water smoke from factories especially in
cities it wasn't crazy to think that
Environmental Quality caused human
bodies to get sick and even in a
cutting-edge facility like Vienna
General patients were lined up in rows
often so close that they could touch
each other's hands in his etiology
semelvice wrote that designers of early
maternity floors of European hospitals
put a privy in the corner but after too
many young mothers disposed of their
newborns by throwing them into the
privies human waste was collected in bed
pans it was not a super luxurious time
to be alive
further complicating miasmic and Cosmic
atmosphere toleric Origins were ideas
that an individual patient's
characteristics and circumstances
contributed to the disease things like
feelings of guilt or shame for pregnancy
out of wedlock a habit of wearing
undergarments too tightly during
pregnancy inadequate nutrition hysteria
depression or just plain underwhelming
genes milk metastasis at least had a
somewhat rational basis a mother
infected with purple fever saw her milk
production dry up right when the Milky
slimy exudate was being produced inside
her so her milk must be spreading around
her body and rotting this jumbled mix of
pseudoscience and mysticism is what
semelvice was up against when as a young
doctor he just had a very simple
question why did so many more mothers
die in the first Clinic than the second
Clinic even without knowing anything
about the disease or how its epidemics
happened he knew there had to be a
difference between the two clinics the
first thing he did was assemble the
statistics between 1841 and 1846 the
first and second clinics had similar
numbers of births around twenty thousand
compared to about 18
000 and while mortality numbers
fluctuated by the year 9.92 percent of
mothers admitted to the first Clinic
died while just 3.9 percent of those in
the second Clinic died a pregnant woman
who was assigned to the first Clinic was
about two and a half times more likely
to never leave the hospital alive than
if she'd just been lucky enough to go to
the second some of us started by
completely rejecting the cosmic
atmospheric toloric theories as being
logically absurd with two clinics
sharing the same Earthly conditions all
of those vague nebulous forces should
affect the populations of both pretty
equally and even if some unseen force
was swirling around the hospital why did
women so often develop pure Pearl fever
in rows affecting some rows and skipping
others did the cosmos play eeny meeny
miny moe and infect women in alternating
straight lines probably not so what he
did was he began to just chip away at
what he saw as a giant logic puzzle the
epidemic influences are working upon the
individual either before her admission
to the lying in hospital or they work
upon her during her stay if they affect
the individual outside the maternity
hospital then those admitted to the
first division are certain as well as
those who present themselves at the
second division for admission to be
exposed to the pernicious action of the
epidemic influences outside the lying in
hospital and then such a great
difference in the mortality ratios could
not exist in the two divisions both of
which admit individuals subject to
epidemic influences okay uh basically if
mothers were catching the disease
outside of the hospital before they were
admitted both Wings would have similar
infection rates some of us concluded
that something was happening inside the
hospital to further bolster that theory
he acknowledged that mothers who gave
birth outside the hospital both the
street births and the ones who didn't
come in at all had very low rates of
pure Pearl fever the hospital was the
problem he put together what would
eventually be 64 tables of of data in
his etiology which showed that there was
no pattern to the swells of epidemic or
receding infection rates the epidemic
influences are so powerful that their
pernicious activity cannot be restrained
at any season of the year that they rage
in the depth of winter and during the
oppressive summer heat with equal
violence however the epidemic influences
are partial and that they do not Scourge
all lying in hospitals to the same
extent but spare certain institutions
and decimate the inmates of others
without Mercy indeed they go so far in
their partiality as even to attack with
unequal severity different sections of
one and the same institution there are
endemic noxious agents which manifest
themselves in such a frightful fashion
only within the limits of the first
obstetrical Clinic awesome
now he just had to figure out what the
problem was was it treatment for the
disease both clinics applied the same
methods and Care once a mother was sick
and both clinics experienced the same
rates of mortality for the infected it
was getting infected in the first place
that was the issue another suggestion
was one of the simplest overcrowding and
the poor conditions that resulted from
it but semelvice dismissed that remember
how mothers were clamoring and literally
scheming to get into the second Clinic
the second Clinic the one with the much
lower mortality rate it was actually the
overcrowded one it was time for the next
Theory blame the priest women were dying
in the first Clinic with such alarming
frequency that a clergyman was available
to administer last rites at all hours of
the day to get to the first Clinic beds
he had to pass through five rooms to get
to the second Clinic beds he passed
through no other rooms was the ever
present priest picking up and carrying
infection semelvice wrote that during my
first term of service I appealed to the
humanity of this servant of God and
without difficulty attained my wish that
the priest in the future should go in a
roundabout way to the wards unattended
and without the ringing of the bell and
without passing through the other Wards
so no one was aware of the presence of
the priest outside of the patients
actually in the ward did it help no it
didn't help nothing changed so he
checked Padre off the list one major
difference between the methods of the
first clinic and the second was the
physician's use of forceps essentially
mechanical baby tongs that could slide
in grab onto a baby's head and
reposition it for an easier their birth
there was some tissue damage when
forceps were used but some of ice
concluded that it was nothing compared
to the extreme strain and destruction of
the birth process itself so forceps
weren't the problem what about
ventilation ventilation was exactly the
same between the clinics and so were the
bed linens so it wasn't it wasn't that
stuff either
semelvice was probably the hardest
working man in Vienna General he woke up
early so he could get a few autopsies in
before committing the rest of his day to
examining patients and treating them he
collected every clue he could like
realizing first time mothers were
particularly susceptible to developing
pure Pearl fever the only significant
operational difference between the two
clinics is that in the first Clinic
mothers gave birth on their backs in the
position we generally use today while in
the second Clinic mothers gave birth on
their sides some of us switched up the
first Clinic to side birthing and
nothing changed meanwhile hospitals in
England didn't have nearly as much of a
child bed Fever problem as Continental
hospitals the English had an early
obsession with basic cleanliness like
clean sheets and floor scrubbing
Professor Johann Klein ran the two
clinics and his predecessor Professor
Bohr adhered to the English cleanliness
model beginning in 1789. over 65
000 deliveries bore oversaw a mortality
rate of 1.3 percent and it was just 0.8
percent in his final year when Klein
took over from boar he discarded the
busy work of frequent cleaning just the
basics were fine okay and cleaning to
the English Standard had no influence on
the cosmic atmospheric toleric factors
anyway and it only had a negligible
effect on the general miasma in Klein's
first year mortality Rose to 7.8 percent
but that was probably just bad luck
right semelvice had been vocal about
trying to crack the code of childbed
fever since he first realized it was an
internal Hospital issue and Klein knew
about some ofice's Ambitions to find a
cure so Klein demoted semelvice a month
after his dismissal the first clinics
abysmal record became a popular
political issue within the emperor's
court and a commission was formed to get
to the bottom of it the commission did
not include semelvice or his supportive
and influential teachers like the
brilliant dermatologist Joseph skoda or
pathologist Carl Vaughn rocketansky the
commission seems to have been
hand-picked by Klein they spent a few
hours at the hospital talked to Klein
for an hour in his office and drew a
single conclusion examinations in the
first Clinic were rougher than those
from the midwives in the second clinic
and caused more tissue damage and who
damages more tissue than anyone men and
foreigners
non-austrians who were judged to be less
gentle than their native counterparts
were removed from the courses of study
and the remaining males were encouraged
to give exams a little more carefully
the clunky Brute Force attitude toward
reaching a solution Echoes a sentiment
from a professor shortly after Vienna
General's founding our ancestors laid
much stress on the success of their
treatment of the sick we however on the
result of our investigations our
tendency is purely scientific The
Physician should be judged by the extent
of his knowledge and not by the number
of his cures it is the investigator not
the Healer that is to be appreciated in
the physician we think of doctors now as
treating patients first and foremost
with research such as a distant second
we generally consider researchers to
occupy a distinctly different role
altogether but in the 18th and 19th
centuries Continental Europe's dangerous
obsession with scientific progress often
trumped everything in training
Physicians including patient care and
outcomes when you went into a hospital
like Vienna General you were thought to
be lucky for the opportunity to Grace
the presence of the most Brilliant Minds
in medicine and you were at their mercy
and pleasure and if you actually got
better well good for you
simulvice just wasn't like that he was
heartbroken by seeing so many mothers
die seemingly needlessly and at random
many who came into the hospital in
perfectly good health investigation was
a necessary part of figuring out what
made child bed fever so deadly but his
Focus was on saving mothers lives and
finally after his tireless pursuit of
uncovering the truth he found his answer
all it took was his friend's bizarre and
untimely death
which delicious hot dog should I
microwave for dinner tonight not at that
because America's number one
Ready-to-Eat meal kit is delivering
fresh never frozen meals to my door so I
don't have to worry about flooding my
exploded hot dog crevice with disgusting
mustard water Factor has plants like
calorie smart keto Protein Plus or
Chef's Choice whatever fits your
personal goals and it's all dietitian
approved so whether you're trying to cut
back on takeout or just want nutritious
meals ready in two minutes without any
prep mess or trips to the grocery store
factor is an unbelievable value and
service and factors now owned by
hellofresh and with a wider array of
meal plans to choose from there's
something for everyone and it's so easy
so head to factor75.com or click the
link below and use code vsauce250 to get
50 off your first Factor box thanks to
them for sponsoring vsauce2 that's
factor75.com and code vsauce250 for 50
percent off your first Factor box
some advice actually had a bit of good
luck for once the man who'd taken his
old position was moving on so he was in
line to take it back he took a short
vacation to Venice but when he returned
he found out that one of his friends and
supporters Jacob kolechka a forensic
medical Professor was dead after
accidentally cutting his finger during
one of those gloveless messy autopsies
he died of pieemia a blood infection
that spread throughout his body
semelvice wrote that he was stuck in the
Finger by a student with a knife that
was used during the post-mortem and died
during my absence in Venice of a
bilateral pleuritus pericarditis
peritonitis and meningitis and some days
before his death a metastasis formed in
one eye they were all the same
afflictions that sembelvice had seen
Time After Time literally ever every
single day of his career at Vienna
General in declining mothers infected
with pure Pearl fever and then in detail
inside their bodies after he dissected
them the problem in the first clinic and
what was driving the inexplicable rise
of purepro fever epidemics in the 1800s
didn't have much to do with motherhood
at all some of us said the exciting
cause of Professor kolechka's illness
was known that is to say the wound
produced by the autopsy knife was
contaminated at the same time by
cadaveric material not the wound but the
contamination of the wound by cadaveric
material was the cause of death it turns
out that doctors and students who spend
the first half of the day rummaging
around the insides of putrid dead bodies
with their bare hands and who then
transfer the cadaver filth directly into
the sense sensitive reproductive tissues
of a woman who is about to have that
entire area ripped apart in childbirth
it turns out they spread a little bit of
disease The Midwives kept their hands at
a dead people's guts everything some of
ice had seen and noticed started to make
sense the data started to make sense
neither the pupils or the midwives in
the second Clinic were spending any time
conducting autopsies they simply were
not coming into contact with dead
rotting tissue that could cause
infection
cool
now what
it's important to realize that in the
1840s no one understood that bacteria or
viruses existed as their own tiny living
particles some of ice couldn't see what
the infecting agent was but he
sure could smell it because the hands
skin and clothes of dissecting
Physicians stunk like dead decaying
bodies all the time sort of like Farmers
smelling like fertilizer you just get
used to it and you don't even notice it
symbolvice once again turned to the
Brilliance of the most simple logic if
he could smell it it's there whatever it
is if the scent is gone it's probably
not there so what would get rid of the
smell as he tried to find a suitable
stink killer the rest of his logic fell
into place why did women develop pure
Pearl fever in Rose because they were
examined in rows with the same infected
hands why did those Street birth women
avoid infection because they never
encountered decaying tissue in the first
place why did the English sanitation
model seem to work better and why did
Vienna's mortality rate Skyrocket when
they gave it up because filth
and it wasn't just hands inserting
tainted forceps was pretty much like
injecting the disease even that weird
blame the foreigners explanation made
sense the foreign students were more
motivated than the Austrian Natives and
participated much more frequently and
actively in autopsies and exams more
involvement equals more infection
starting in May of 1847 semelvice
decided on a mixture of chlorinated lime
and mandated that all staff washed their
hands with it before examining patients
bowls of chlorinated water with sand for
scrubbing were placed at the entrances
of the clinic hand washing itself wasn't
new but since soap and water didn't take
away the dead body smell semelvice knew
it wasn't negating the infecting agent
in June the mortality rate was down to
2.38 percent
in July
1.2 and in August it was 1.89
semelvice had the data but Klein his
Superior was Furious and the staff
absolutely hated doing it that part kind
of makes sense think about it from a
medical student's perspective you're
you're being forced to cover your skin
in a serious irritant when soap and
water seems to do just fine it smells
terrible there's a reason why chlorine
gas was an effective chemical weapon in
World War one it's noxious and hard on
the lungs and why exactly are you doing
this to supposedly combat something you
can't see and which runs counter to
thousands of years of medical wisdom
because a weird little man is making you
do it despite his own boss telling
everyone it's stupid it it also wasn't
foolproof and semelvice was forced to
continually refine his theory when 11 of
12 women in a row of beds all contracted
purple fever it seemed to completely
disprove the semelvice chlorine washing
Doctrine but after investigating the
scenario it turned out that the first
patient was suffering from uterine
cancer and decayed tissue and discharge
contaminated her examiner's hands which
also meant two new pieces of information
the infection didn't just come from dead
bodies in the morgue and only washing
her hands with chlorine on the way into
the clinic wasn't enough now all of the
examining materials had to be washed
constantly and those students and nurses
who complained about chlorine washing
upon entrance were now being told to do
it after seeing every single patient
the results were fantastic and semelvice
was sure they'd speak for themselves
but he was wrong
catastrophically wrong because his
reward for saving countless mothers and
babies lives
was the complete and utter destruction
of his own colleagues who found his
Discovery compelling encouraged him to
publish his findings everywhere he could
not least of which was the relevant
medical journals of the day he refused
repeatedly citing his discomfort with
writing after all why did it matter he
was training foreign doctors who would
go home to their native countries and
spread his methods to the world he
really just wanted to save lives as the
Revolutions of 1848 escalated throughout
Europe Vienna was one of its centers
some of us were the uniform of an
academic Legion that supported reforms
and Hungarian Independence After the
Revolution was suppressed in 1849 those
who had remained loyal to the Austrian
Empire wielded an even greater power
than before
Klein still symbolizes boss and by now
Nemesis was one of them in March of that
year Klein fired samovlice despite the
first Clinic's mortality rates finally
being below the second clinics and he
replaced him with a man who had invented
a decapitation hook for cutting up
babies who died within their mother's
womb sweet and although a few others
were writing about his chlorine regiment
and its Effectiveness they often got one
major detail wrong they only mentioned
cadaverous tissue contamination leaving
out that living organisms could spread
infection it seems like a tiny detail
but it was a fatal flaw it meant that
when others tried to replicate an
incomplete semelvice Doctrine it simply
wouldn't work consistently and if it's
not consistent then the real cause must
be something else a hospital in Prague
delivered a serious blow to the theory
for a month and a half they instituted
chlorine washing and reduced their
visits to the Pathology Lab they
observed no decrease in infection and
after they stopped the epidemic went
away on its own it just turns out that
they implemented the system badly and
fudges the data a century later Frank G
Slaughter said of the refutation of
semifice the hole is a sickening
document of interest in showing with
what energy and Ingenuity men can
conduct themselves in the fight against
truth semelvice had made a discovery
that would change the world and almost
no one believed him
he returned to Budapest and managed the
clinic at St rokus he implemented his
chlorine regimen and over the course of
six years the number of mothers who died
from purebroil fever was
0.85 percent
and no one cared except his critics
Carl Braun the Klein loving decapitation
tool Professor who replaced him in
Vienna published a list of 30 causes of
pure Pearl fever including High room
temperature and the emotions of the
mother
he buried cadaveral tissue contact in
point number 28.
some of us came to understand that
nearly all the critics supposed failures
of his method were the result of
inadequate implementation like the time
when an epidemic broke out in his own
Clinic he traced it back to a lazy nurse
who didn't bother changing bed linens of
the infected when a new patient was put
in the bed he grew increasingly
frustrated after another outbreak he
found out that the hospital had
contracted with the lowest priced
laundry service to wash patient Linens
when he realized they were shipping the
Linens back to the hospital without
washing them at all samovice threw the
pus covered bedding at the face of the
hospital administrator who was trying to
save a buck as his resentment grew he
burned so many bridges and provoked so
many critics by threatening the medical
and scientific establishments that his
personality started to change he did get
married to a woman who made him very
happy and his wife then became pregnant
but the baby died days after birth they
tried again and that daughter died from
peritonitis after just four months he
was at times racked by guilt over having
spent so many years inadvertently
infecting mothers so many of them so
young and sending them to an early death
how many thousands were killed under his
watch it ate away at him he wrote God
only knows the number of women I have
consigned prematurely to the Grave for I
have occupied myself with the cadaver to
a degree reached by few Obstetricians
and he wasn't alone in his grief the
obstetrician Gustav mikolis who himself
was a Pioneer in the field he did
groundbreaking research on the role of
the narrow pelvis in childbirth learned
of samovic's methods and became a strict
practitioner of chlorine washing he
eventually realized that his prior
techniques had resulted in the deaths of
so many women including his own niece he
never got over knowing that he was the
reason she died that's why he threw
himself under a train
in Hamburg but no matter how bad things
got semelvice knew he was saving lives
by the thousands and his under one
percent mortality rate at the pesh
Clinic continued to prove it finally
after a decade of refusal he decided to
write and publish his treaty on the
prevention of pure Pearl fever his
525-page book The etiology concept and
prophylaxis of childbed fever is one of
the most comprehensive exhaustive works
of medical literature in history he
detailed every piece of his own
professional experience before
identifying what child bed fever is
laying bare all its known causes and
prescribing every measure to prevent its
contraction and spread before devoting
over a hundred pages to addressing the
voluminous criticism of his theories
Wikipedia gives a single short paragraph
to the medical magnum opus that ended up
saving millions of mothers
the book explains how his research shows
that hand hygiene in hospitals can
prevent unnecessary deaths you would
just think it'd be more of a big deal
but guess not Vice had discovered his
life-saving chlorine Revolution while he
was still in his 20s by his late 30s
when he began writing his etiology his
personality really started to change he
was incredibly kind with his patience
and although he'd always been difficult
with everyone else he was getting worse
historianist Von Benedict wrote that his
whole life shows clearly that he was a
psychopathic personality he was
tormented irritable hot tempered mono
maniacally clinging to his own sphere of
thought and consequence quarrelsome even
with his friends rash and his judgment
on those who looked unfavorably upon his
hypothesis often coarse Benedict said he
even started to argue with his friends
ranting so excitedly that they just
didn't want to be around him anymore he
started to attack his critics in the
medical press with a series of open
letters that were dripping with
infective and personal insults he ran
the numbers on his old clinic in Vienna
finding that in the decade after he left
[Music]
1924 women died needlessly from Pure
Pearl fever he wrote in this massacre
you hair Professor have participated
there is no other course open for me
except to keep watch and every man who
dares spread dangerous errors regarding
peripheral fever will find in me an
active opponent this murder must cease
and in order that the murder ceases I
will keep watch and anyone who dares to
propagate dangerous errors about child
bed fever will find in me an eager
adversary in order to put an end to
these murders I have no resort but to
mercilessly expose my adversaries and no
one whose heart is in the right place
will criticize me for seizing this
expedient he derided one of his harshest
critics Friedrich Wilhelm scanzoni for
publishing a history of childbed fever
that ran counter to his theories of
contagion and prophylaxis his response
to scanzoni was Savage should you
without having disproved my Doctrine
continue to train your pupils in the
doctrine of epidemic childbed fever I
declare before God and the world that
you are a murderer and the history of
childbed fever would not be on just to
you if it memorialized you as a medical
Nero an obstetrics professor at Freiburg
described how semifice would confront
total strangers on the street not
Physicians or students just normal
people walking by to argue about the
superiority and necessity of his
chlorine Doctrine he began drinking
heavily and spending a great deal of
time with a prostitute he boasted to
friends and colleagues about his massive
wealth despite having none at all but
the most shocking evidence of his
decline is the comparison of two photos
of semelvice one at the prime of his
personal and professional life he and
his wife had three more healthy children
who lived he had successfully
administered all his clinics and saved
more lives than he could ever begin to
count he was just about to embark on
writing one of the most important texts
in medical history he was robust serious
and still only 39 years old
just three years later he was elderly
he'd turned completely gray he was frail
in his three years of writing and
arguing he aged about 30.
at a dinner with friends he rose and
began an excited speech of entirely
unintelligible words his wife took him
home at a department meeting he began
reading from a piece of paper he was
reciting the midwife's oath which had
nothing at all to do with the topic at
hand there are several different
theories to explain semelvice's Decline
and all of them have compelling elements
one historian guessed that he had
acquired early onset dementia in the
form of Alzheimer's disease his
confusion erratic behavior and mental
decline seemed to fit that a more modern
theory is that he began to suffer from
bipolar disorder in his 30s his Vicious
Cycles of manic professional
productivity and depressive lulls
support that another suggests he was
afflicted with Advanced syphilis and
that's possible too as it wasn't
uncommon for gynecologists and autopsy
Specialists to contract the disease
but he also was just a Broken Man
broken from the weight of human
suffering much of which was at his own
hands broken from the pushback of the
scientific and medical community who
largely rejected what he knew would
eventually save Millions
his colleagues and wife agreed that he
needed to be taken to a sanatorium in
Vienna for mental health treatment he
tried to leave he said he needed to get
back to attend to his patients and he
was forcibly restrained by six staff
they put semelvice in his straight
jacket and locked him in a dark room
14 days later
he was dead
almost no one went to his funeral
not his children not even his wife
his autopsy showed that he'd been
severely beaten multiple times and it
also showed a small cut on his finger
and these same symptoms of pyemia
infection that killed his colleague
kolechka years prior
died from the same exact streptococcal
infection that had killed an
incalculable number of innocent mothers
in the last century and the exact same
infection he dedicated his life
to preventing
Joseph Lister began implementing his use
of carbolic acid for antisepsis on
August 12 1865 two days before semelvice
died you may have rinsed your mouth with
Listerine this morning and if not you
still know what it is in 1879 the
chemist and germ Theory Pioneer Louis
Pasteur was at a conference in Paris
discussing purple fever where Jacques
ervo the man who had likened childbed
fever to war blamed the epidemic on foul
miasma Pastor interrupted him saying
none of those things caused the epidemic
it is the nursing and medical staff who
carry the microbe from an infected woman
to a healthy one when ervo told Pastor
that he was afraid the organism at fault
can never be seen or found Pastor went
to the chalkboard drew a diagram of
Streptococcus bacteria and said there
that is what it looks like and you know
pestor you might have drank
pasteurized milk today too
but I can guarantee you've never
semelvised your hands to kill the
bacteria on them and when you skinned
your knee as a kid your mom didn't Semel
Vice the wound before she put the
Band-Aid on
belief perseverance is a desire to
continue to adhere to a belief even
after new information
completely disproves it and sometimes it
can even strengthen the refuted belief
especially when it contradicts centuries
of professional wisdom Timothy Leary
described a special strain of belief
perseverance as mob Behavior found among
primates and larval hominids on
undeveloped planets in which a discovery
of important scientific fact is punished
he called it this Semel Vice reflex
it's all so hard to believe that it
makes for outstanding drama in Henry
ibsen's 1882 play an enemy of the people
Dr Thomas Stockman reveals a bacterial
contamination in a local spa and for
that public service he is punished
severely the 1939 Oscar winner for best
short subject starred Shepard strudwick
as a struggling semelvice in that
mothers might live and at the Harold
Pinter theater in London's West End the
two and a half hour Dr semelvice is
playing right now
was ignis samovice just a sad
unfortunate victim of his own
revolutionary progress was it his own
fault for not publishing his results
sooner and for fighting with virtually
everyone including his own friends or
was he fated to be like Cassandra in
Greek mythology who was given the gift
of Prophecy but cursed so that no one
would ever believe her warnings
probably
all of it
theoretical physicist Max Planck said a
scientific truth does not Triumph by
converting its opponents and making them
see the light but rather because its
opponents eventually die in a new
generation grows up that is familiar
with it ignis semelvice condensed his
own story one of the most tumultuous
biographies in scientific history
into a single sentence
my doctrines exist to rid maternity
hospitals of their horror
to preserve the wife for her husband
and the mother
for her child
and because of that
you are alive
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]